the health district is now offering
second doses of the coven 19 vaccine at
cashman center now compared to last week
people say they're getting the vaccines
a lot quicker joe mohler is live at the
convention center with more on that and
also some other changes that are going
on
joe well cashman center and the las
vegas convention center where we are at
are both going to be having the second
dose now we'll take a live look at the
parking lot here at the convention
center last week it was full
and had long lines and people were
waiting several hours
now let's go ahead and get into the
video of these lines from last week
hundreds of people were waiting some up
to four hours some a little longer than
that
well today the process was much quicker
at the convention center and also over
at cashman
people were waiting in an hour and a
half at the convention center to get in
which is a lot sooner than last week
now earlier we did speak with bill
vickers who said he was in and out at
cashman in about 20 minutes or so
he said he was worried because he could
not book that appointment online
i called this morning they said they had
an appointment at 11 a.m
i came down i was in and out in 20
minutes
now the health district urges people who
may have made multiple appointments to
cancel their duplicate appointments to
allow someone else in need
to get the vaccine now people are
provided a link to do so
they should check their spam or junk
folder if they cannot find that email
you can also call 702-759-1900
for help now back out here live we're
taking another live look at the parking
lot here
just about an hour ago the cars were
full but people are wrapping up their
appointments here now after those
lengthy lines that were happening last
week the health district is no longer
accepting walk-ins
here at the convention center so you
must have an appointment both for this
location and at cashman
and in the past cashman has been a
testing site for copa 19 but starting on
friday
they will no longer be doing testing
there they'll be expanding other
locations
reporting live the convention center joe
muller 8 news now